can a wireless charger really be worth a
hundred and fifty dollars or is this
thing just a rip-off well today i am
reviewing the new boost charge pro and
also comparing it to the three-in-one
belkin that i've used for over a year
and i have to say that over a year ago i
would say that no this is a rip off but
now i have changed my mind and for a
couple good reasons because this has
some features that no other charger has
multiples and they also teach us
something about the new apple watch
series 7 and the upcoming series 8. i've
been a huge fan of wireless charging
ever since the iphone 8 came out with
its glass back and wireless charger but
back then there were a few major issues
with wireless chargers but now with the
iphone 12 and the iphone 13s we have
even more issues and different things
that we have to deal with that i will
get into now when those first iphones
came out i bought a couple cheap
wireless chargers and they were okay the
biggest issue was the fact that if you
don't align it perfectly you end up
either not getting a charge or getting a
very slow one now there are also other
options coming out like certain
three-in-one chargers which i loved
because it gives you all the convenience
of charging your airpods your apple
watch but with those you have to add
your own puck and they had other issues
as well such as sometimes i wake up in
the morning and my phone would just be
dead because the charger just stopped in
the middle of the night apple decided to
fix those issues when they launched
magsafe with the iphone 12s allowing
your phone to magnetically attach and
fix the biggest issue which is the
proper alignment and getting the full
speed when you charge now the other part
as far as third-party chargers sucking
well that just got worse because with
the new iphones having the ability to
have 15 watts of max safe charging is
really nice and fast but all these
advertisers started claiming 15 watts on
their chargers even though some of them
only gave like five watts to your iphone
and then they still would be flaky that
is where this belkin came out last year
and this thing was 140 bucks it's a
three in one charger that allows you to
charge your air pods your apple watch
and your iphone with the full
performance so 15 watts for your iphone
the full speed for everything else now
when that came out i had the question am
i going to regret spending 140 bucks on
this because that is a whole lot of
money and i have to say that a year
later almost a year later i have no
regrets it is literally one of my
favorite purchases but now we have this
brand new charger from belkin that has
some unique features but my first
thought was
why in the world did they go from this
design right here
to this flat design it is great having
this look where everything is just right
there you can actually keep your phone
on you can watch something when it's on
your bedside it just looks really nice
and they're going to something like this
and at the same time they're charging 10
extra dollars for it well after checking
this thing out it makes a whole lot of
sense first off when you look at this
obviously it's a much smaller profile
everything is flat even though it is
quite heavy and this thing feels
extremely extremely solid now their
biggest thing is the fact that one this
is the only charger that can fast charge
apple watch series 7 so 33 faster
charging and 2 this thing is also
portable with this three-in-one charger
that i've used and loved you're not
going to be taking this on your trip
it's just too bulky you're going to
leave it so when you're going to trip
you got to take with you three separate
chargers or you have to use one charger
for multiple devices the other option is
buying apple's air power but i
personally could not stomach spending
130 bucks not even getting a power
adapter
and the fact that even with a 20 watt
charger you're only getting 11 watts to
your iphone if you buy a newer more
powerful one you could get 14 so still
not the same 15 but even with that said
if you're charging both your apple watch
and you are charging your iphone at the
same time you get even slower speed so
that is a major bummer now what i did
personally is i bought one of these
third-party ones that do not support 15
watt mag safe but the air power still
doesn't or their max they do i should
call it um so i got one of these but
it's still flaky it would still flake
out of me sometimes it would not work
it's very slow so i would not recommend
this so now i see
why belkin went with this model where
it's slim it is nice and compact and if
you're heading somewhere you could toss
this in your bag and when you arrive you
have full fast charging for your iphone
for any other regular device or air pods
along with your apple watch including
the series 7 which this is the only fast
charger as i already mentioned and of
course apple's sticking with max a for a
long time and this wireless charging
standard now that the series 7 has fast
charging so when you pick one of these
up you know that's not going to last you
half a year or a year and be flaky and
die out it's going to last for a year so
it's a great investment now with that
like i mentioned the build quality is
really good when you compare it to the
previous one this one feels even more
solid on the top they have the silicon
type texture
it's not as grippy as the previous one
so it's easier to clean but it feels
really nice the magnets built into the
mac safe connection here they're nice
they feel like they're slightly less
powerful because it doesn't need a hang
there so it's easy to pick up your
device but with that it aligns perfectly
and then the space here for your
air
we do still have that little led which
is a downside that's really the only
issue i had with the previous one and
then for your apple watch charger if you
have an apple watch strap that opens up
like mine does right here you just set
it down like that
or if you have one that doesn't you can
actually pop this up and then you can
attach it or if you like using the
nightstand mode it can also work that
way so you can have your time visible
now with that on the bottom we do have
some adjustments so if you have an older
apple watch that's smaller you go to the
base setting if you have one like i do
you can just kind of twist it and adjust
for the larger size actually all the way
here and that will kind of raise it give
this little lip just like the maxi
charger and allow it to sit really
nicely and fit on this device now i also
said that we found out something about
the apple watch 37 with this charger and
that is the fact that the new series
sevens they don't actually use any more
power
so if we take a look at this new uh
boost charge pro the input wattage is 40
watts just like the previous one and the
power adapters to both
they
are also identical meaning that it the
change in the series seven is just the
fact that as a more efficient coil it's
maybe more tightly wound less
loss so you're getting better energy
efficiency and that is what is helping
you get 33
faster charging less limitations better
efficiency so that is interesting but
unfortunately if you have an older
charger or any other third-party charger
that might be 80 bucks instead of 150
you're not gonna get the full speed for
the series seven or the newer watches
and two you're not getting 15 watts of
magsafe charging you're gonna get only
7.5 now of course the other benefit of
this that actually comes with the power
adapter
one downside to this not usb type c i
would have loved it if it was it's the
same one with this little barrel plug
but when you set this up
this has a nice little hidden channel so
that you can
connect the cable in here you plug it in
and then you have a nice clean run off
of your desk and only one adapter to
plug into the wall instead of having
multiples or extra cables that go from
one device to the other like cheaper
three-in-one chargers that we have
tested and reviewed so with all that
said how does a new boost charge pro
compare to their previous three in one
that they are still selling on the
website well first off this thing is
about 10 bucks cheaper if you buy on
apple's
site but it does have a very long wait i
think it's over a month month and a half
to actually receive it
i do really like this setup where you
see your iphone and you see the apple
watch on here as well i think it is very
nice visually and it looks great on a
nightstand i do not like this flat
layout as much but with that said after
getting it having the ability to just
toss this into a bag and take it with
you is really nice and then having the
future proofing of the fast charging
for newer apple watches 33 faster i
think that is another great feature and
if i was choosing one over the other it
would definitely be this new version no
doubt about it and if you're still on
the edge about buying one of these for
150 or something cheaper for
50 60 bucks that you have to add your
own apple watch charger to or maybe 80
90. i would definitely say spend the
extra money have the proper alignment
proper certification for actual true max
a 15 watt from apple the faster speeds
and just the reliability knowing you're
getting a good product that's not could
you just die out you know a year or two
or even sometimes six months from the
time you buy it it's definitely worth it
and you will not regret it even though
it costs a lot and it's hard to swallow
that amount so this is the best charger
on the market offering things that no
other one offers and i do think it is
worth it until apple comes out and makes
something that's their own that is gonna
work well and give you proper speeds not
like that magsafe duo that is just
it's pretty much just an embarrassment
so there you guys go uh i'll have links
everything down in the description below
click that circle above if you guys want
to help us reach our goal of a million
subscribers check out those videos right
over there this one max and i will see
you in the next video
[Music]